hey Luke here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel today I'm in Las Vegas
and we're gonna show you some real
outside-the-box fun you can have in this
crazy City
you know to play out like it I'm heading
downstairs now I'm gonna get picked up
by a Humvee and go to a place where I
can shoot incredibly large guns I'm
going to Battlefield Vegas we'd be
shooting some guy
My Ride just big deal
holy crap realize that I don't have as
much time as I need to do everything I
want to do holy mackerel
yeah check that out
holy Becker I want to shoot that
displacement it's if you like guns this
is the stuff magic the paraphernalia
guns got RPGs over there so definitely
interesting but I want to check outside
here you know this place actually rents
the tank and for like $3,000 or
something you can rent the tape and then
drive over a car that Tommy would love
as Nathan would love this too but
unfortunately I think you have to be
like 13 or something come here and shoot
so the boys are too young had to leave
them at home these are all the Humvees
they'll come pick you up at your hotel
hey guys check it out I'm gonna Hughie
huh this is cool you can climb into all
this stuff yeah you're gonna get a play
with all the little joysticks even
though Tommy and Nathan are too young to
shoot the guns if I hadn't known they
had all this stuff here I would have
brought them just to be able to play
inside that helicopter that's so cool oh
ho ho ho this is like a legit Museum
here oh yeah well it's a hundred and
eight degrees here in Las Vegas and as
much fun as riding in that Humvee was I
have a new respect for all you guys who
served in Iraq and drove around and
Humvees wearing fatigues and gear and a
hundred plus degrees I was sweating it
out in just my t-shirt by the way I can
hear a speaker there they're playing
chatter between ground forces and aerial
forces in combat it's kind of nice guy
you come in and check in guys get all
your guns and ammo ready and then they
paid you with this little thingamajiggy
when you're ready and you can just check
out all the tanks and everything while
you wait all right guys it's go time
[Music]
Semmy and all very light recoil you can
switch it to full auto whenever you're
ready to okay simple school kind of a
short stock so you gotta tuck it in yeah
all right that's kind of fun that's
pretty cool yeah pretty fun little gun
yeah yeah that is that is fun so f2000
of course this is a five five six rifle
you're gonna have full control over the
automatic and the semi-automatic in the
trigger so single all the way back for
auto interested it's a two-stage trigger
that is hard to control it catches you
off-guard doesn't it yeah its end up too
much fun guys this is this is like a
buffet of ammunition oh is this what
they call a saw like the squad operated
weapon kind of thing
that is a lot easier to keep on target
soup that thing doesn't twit I've kind
of forgotten what I ordered
so the fact he's pulling out these large
pieces of metal is very ominous well I
got a feeling we're gonna be using I
used a little peep sight okay front
sight hard upward squeeze on that
trigger okay
3:30 on 6:30 at 6:00 holy mackerel shot
a bolt-action thirty out six this is
gonna be way better
that is one of my favorite weapons here
yeah yeah figure the recoil springs
about that long barrel reciprocate and
they comp sense all that pressure so
that's that's nice I I felt that my my
forehead if you don't have a fantasy
about shooting a minigun you're not into
guns that's just how it is this is gonna
be awesome
three two one
I knew it's gonna be cool that was
cooler than I thought
yeah I actually hit something oh yeah
yeah a gut shot him but it'll do the job
quantity not quality that's right what
that is right there look at that so
we're gonna go do the vault tour
oh holy mackerel
look at that that smells manly so what's
your favorite gun what's what's your
favorite my all-time favorite is the m1
garand the m14 it's a good sturdy gun
right there's old fast World War two
it's the one that you see in the movies
where the clip pops up yeah once you're
done love it yeah that's cool even have
the golden a kay if you're into James
Bond Goldeneye there Hello Kitty ak-47
awesome boy is that beast oh man oh
that's an tight I almost got that well
that's the anti-tank one right it's the
lobby Oh virginal chamber in 20
millimeter ours is chambered in 50 yeah
I just finished my rounds this is
awesome guys oh these H case yep I don't
know a lot I've recognized again
everyone and you know wine pigs and
acorns and everything please look at
this this is just pistols holy mackerel
and just a casual it was that fifty
callus yeah the m2g that's what the goes
on top of the Humvees right yeah so it's
like the 1919 you fired just much much
bigger much much bigger geez and then an
RPG you see it's a dummy ground I assume
about to say that looked like a nerf
blaster but that's a that's an automatic
shotgun isn't it semi-auto that's a
grenade launcher right yeah sure that's
cool so what did the dummy rounds do
they just bounced off the wall guys
definitely you got to check out
battlefield Vegas if you have two
minutes to rub together in Las Vegas
check this place out I'll put a link in
the description to their details and
their website this is a pretty
affordable way to fulfill your bucket
list that was awesome
I got a grin plastered from ear to ear
bed that was cool that was cool pretty
affordable I mean if you just want to
try out a gun you can try out a lot of
different guns for a pretty reasonable
price if you liked this video don't
forget to check out our 2018 World Tour
where we spent five weeks traveling all
over Asia in North America and having
all sorts of great adventures it's a
twelve part series and is absolutely
amazing so don't forget to click
Subscribe for more adventures for the
outro boys YouTube channel and click the
link below to see more videos from this
trip